the benefits of moringa okay the moringa
plant
it's actually a tree and a lot of people
wanted me to do a video on this so i
finally
decided to do it it's called the miracle
tree
because every part of this tree has
very special properties from the
leaves to the flowers to the seeds to
the bark to the sap to the pods
the oil has certain properties that are
similar to olive oil
and what's interesting it doesn't go
rancid so apparently it's
so loaded with antioxidants it's
protected
but here's some of the benefits first of
all it has all
of the essential amino acids number two
it has seven times the potassium as
bananas
three twice as much protein as milk four
times as much calcium as milk
number five seven times more vitamin c
than an orange
number six 25 times the iron than
spinach now of course it's not the heme
iron
but it's still some iron that can be
converted or used by our bodies
to a certain degree number seven it has
36 times more magnesium
than eggs and number eight it has 50
times more
vitamin b3 than peanuts it has 56 times
more vitamin b2
than bananas and number 10 it has
anti-diabetic properties so it's
great if you have blood sugar issues
number 11 is anti-arthritic so it has
powerful anti-inflammatory properties
all right number 12 it's a very very
powerful antioxidant
and number 13 it's anti acne so moringa
is definitely on the list of superfoods
not only
the massive amount of nutrients but also
phytonutrients hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would
love to hear about your success story
please share it
in the link down below